auch wenn es weh tut wir müssen leider
noch über die unverdienten Sieger des
vergangenen Wochenendes reden ja es
hilft nichts es hilft nichts meine Damen
und
hat er jetzt gerade den FC Bayern
München Erdogan verglichen ja hat er
weil das kann
zu privat Erdogan siegt in der Stichwahl
am vergangenen Sonntag und hat nun
mindestens fünf weitere Jahre Zeit die
Türkei endgültig in einer Autokratie zu
verwandeln hier seine ersten Gratulanten
so haben etwa der russische Präsident
Putin der ungarische Ministerpräsident
Viktor Orban wie auch die militant
islamistische Taliban Regierung in
Afghanistan zum Wahl sie gratuliert ja
danach hat Gianni Infantino angerufen
dann Hannibal Lecter und dann Sauron
Ferngespräch aus Moordorf
und Scholz haben auch gratuliert mit
gerade mal 4% Punkten Vorsprung schlägt
Erdogan seinen Herausforderer obwohl er
80% der türkischen Medien kontrolliert
der Sultan ist trotzdem gerührt
hauptsächlich von sich selbst
wir lieben ihn wir lieben ihn sind
Erdogan da in einer liebeshymne an sich
selbst nachdem fast alle Stimmen
ausgezählt sind mein Gott
der Recep sinkt ja verschlechter als er
regiert
ein Liebeslied an sich selbst wie schön
kann man übrigens sogar bestellen die
erdo love songs mit allen großen
selbstverliebtheitsballaden wie zum
Beispiel ohne mich schlafe ich heute
nacht nicht ein
told me lately that I love me
I was made for loving me Baby und
natürlich I just call to say I love you
die Erde love songs jetzt bestellen oder
sie wandern in den Knast
ach ja
schlimmes Wochenende war das insgesamt
vor allem aber was für ein bitterer
Sonntag für Türken die auf mehr
Demokratie gehofft hatten ebenso für
alle Schweden die gerne in die NATO
wollen und ich sag mal so die
Zusammenarbeit mit der EU wird auch
nicht leichter ein türkischer
EU-Beitritt ist fast schon EU möglich ja
auf solche Gags müssen Sie jetzt auf
solche Gags müssen sie jetzt wochenlang
verzichten
Erdogan Sieg eine katastrophale
Nachricht für die türkische Wirtschaft
die Inflationsrate liegt bei denen jetzt
schon bei über
40%, weil der selbst ernannte topökonom
Pato die Zinsen nicht erhöhen will die
Lira kannst du eigentlich nur noch als
Türstopper benutzen oder verschenken
bitte hat er gemacht
schon am Vormittag vor dem Wahllokal
gibt sich Erdogan im feiertagsmodus
verteilt wie sonst nur ein Festtagen
üblich ist mir wahrscheinlich so gehen
direkt Zahlung ans Volker Lindner es ist
doch total simpel
blöd nur dass die türkischen Scheine so
rasant an Wert verlieren fürs nächste
WLAN kaufen erdo würde ich lieber eine
stabilere Währung nehmen
sanifarbons oder so
als erste Idee
Erdogan triumphiert schon wieder
ja vor allem in Deutschland vor allem in
Deutschland wo er prozentual sogar
besser abschneidet als in der Türkei
tatsächlich haben ihn absoluten Zahlen
von 1,5 Millionen türkisch ständigen
wahlberechtigten und 500.000 ihr Kreuz
bei Erdogan gemacht man könnte auch
sagen die haben von einer sicheren
Demokratie aus dafür gesorgt dass andere
anderswo weiter in einer Autokratie
leben müssen aus völlig
unterschiedlichen Motiven natürlich war
wohl so 10% sagen ich kann meine
Verwandtschaft in der Türkei nicht ab
und möchte dass es den möglichst
schlecht geht 9% wollen dass die Lehrer
noch weiter in den Keller rauscht damit
sie billig in der Türkei Urlaub machen
können ja und die restlichen 81% wollten
einfach nur Champ Agner
in der Realität fühlen sich wohl viele
Deutsche Türken von der
Mehrheitsgesellschaft zu wenig
akzeptiert und das verstehe ich aber ist
das wirklich ein Grund Erdogan zu wählen
vor allem im Ruhrgebiet hat der tierisch
abgeräumt in Essen z.B gab's endlose
Auto korsi falls das der Plural ist
ich denke wir sind uns einig seit dieser
Woche ist aber auch mal endgültig
Schluss mit den doofen Witzen über Joe
bidens Alter der Mann steht voll im Saft
also außer wenn er gerade stolpert
natürlich ja aber er hat Last Minute
last minute den Kompromiss zum
Schuldenstreit ausgehandelt und damit
quasi die Weltwirtschaft gerettet das
gibt Rückenwind im Wahlkampf gegen
Donald Trump falls der denn am Ende
beiden Gegner wird denn nun hat auch
rondes aus Florida offiziell seine
Kandidatur erklärt so oder so es wird in
jedem Fall schmutzig Friedemann Weise
stimmt uns ein Haus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
beim Kampf ums Weiße Haus schmeißt der
nächste weiße Mann seinen Cowboyhut in
den Ring Florida governight hat in Yale
und Herbert studiert war beim Militär
und ist sein Pudding angeblich nicht mit
einem Löffel sondern mit drei Fingern
auch sonst alles ganz normal eine Frau
drei Kinder und ein sympathisches
ansteckendes Lachen
jetzt weiß ich endlich warum man sagt
lachen bis der Arzt kommt am meisten
Hass kam natürlich von Trump der
behauptet sein ehemaliger Schützling
klaut ihm seine Ideen dabei sind es doch
nicht nur seine Ideen
haben sie gesehen der unterschreibt mit
einem Filzstift genau wie Trump warum
nimmt er nicht seine puddingfinger das
Problem ist ja auch eher was die Cent
ist alles unterschreibt er hat die
Todesstrafe erleichtert das Waffenrecht
gelockert Abtreibung nach der sechsten
Woche verboten die Themen sexuelle
Orientierung und Rassismus in Schulen
für Tabu erklärt er hätte gerne noch
mehr solcher menschenverachtenden
Gesetze unterschrieben aber der Tisch
war leider voll und trotzdem wird die
Säntis in den Medien immer als Trump mit
Hirn bezeichnet natürlich kriegt er auch
ordentlich Gegenwind für seine
diskriminierende Politik nicht zuletzt
bei Disney dem größten privaten
Arbeitgeber in Florida gab es viele
Demos und Proteste seitdem herrscht
offener Krieg zwischen dezentes und
Disney der streng gläubige Katalog hat
panische Angst davor dass der Vocal
Disney Konzern unsere Kinder total
versext mit Filmen wie sex toy Story
oder
fistet Nemo oder noch schlimmer
schneewokchen und die sieben gender ich
würde es gucken die Cent ist nicht für
ihn sind die Bogen eine Bedrohung und er
ist bereit zu kämpfen
wir bekämpfen woknis in der Gesetzgebung
in den Schulen in der Bürokratie in der
Wirtschaft wir geben uns nicht den
Gurken Mob komisch irgendwie kommt mir
das gerade alles so bekannt vor ob ich
das denn neulich schon mal gehört
oh nein ich habe Angst in Amerika kommt
bald der Trump mit hören und wir kriegen
einen
Trump mit Hut
ja toll
zurück nach Deutschland tschüss
[Applaus]
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an